Candace Cameron Bure opens up about her
past struggles battling an eating
disorder I knew I had it had a problem
but again it's like being on a runaway
train here going I want to get off I
don't know how to get off don't know how
to get off
sadly thirty million Americans are
affected by eating disorders a year the
40-year old actress says she was part of
that statistic back in her 20s when she
took a break from Hollywood to focus on
her marriage and raise her family I kind
of lost my identity in a sense and what
happened was I turned to food for
comfort when my husband was traveling
when I was alone and I developed a very
unhealthy relationship with food that
turned into bulimia and you know it's I
dealt with it for several several years
but it wasn't about body image it wasn't
about trying to look good it was all
about trying to find comfort or fill
voids within myself the fuller house
star revealed the exact moment she knew
she needed help I was sitting in church
and I was by myself my husband was on
the road it's when I went directly to my
pastor I was like I just I need help and
it felt so good to admit it to someone
that was just the moment that I when I
don't want to do this anymore
Candace admitted at first she was
embarrassed to tell her husband but said
he's been incredibly supportive together
they're teaching their kids about having
healthy body image the most important
thing for me to teach my children my
daughter and my two boys is about health
health and fitness it's just about
living a healthy life for longevity and
healthy heart